Уже третій рік поспіль влада і "євробляхери" не можуть порозумітися.
Обіцяного розмитнення завезених з-за кордону автомобілів за доступними цінами так і немає,
власників автівок на іноземній реєстрації вже почали штрафувати,
а "секонд-хенду на колесах" на українських дорогах не меншає.
Чому вже стільки років влада не може врегулювати цю проблему і який вихід?
Таке явище як "євробляхи" поширилося в Україні, коли почалася війна на Донбасі.
Волонтери поставляли автівки з європейською реєстрацією для потреб військових на передовій.
Влада цьому не заважала і не ставилася прискіпливо до перевірки умов розмитнення.
Цим скористалися й ті, хто не хотів розмитнювати машини для свої потреб.
З'явилися різні схеми, як обійти законодавство, і це переросло у величезний бізнес.
Першу спробу владнати проблему зробили за часів Порошенка в 2018-му.
Тоді ухвалили два закони.
Одним запровадили нову формулу розрахунку акцизного податку і надали можливість розмитнення за зниженими ставками.
Цим скористалися, за офіційними даними, 218 тисяч автовласників і сплатили до бюджету понад 13 мільярдів гривень.
А другим законом підвищили розміри штрафів за порушення термінів розмитнення "євроблях" - до 170 тисяч гривень.
Але другий закон фактично так і не почав діяти. Запровадження штрафів постійно відтерміновували - востаннє вже за Зеленського.
Крім того, громадське об’єднання "АвтоЄвроСила" та МВС домовилися, що "євробляхерів" не притягатимуть до відповідальності
доки не ухвалять новий закон про ще більш доступне розмитнення.
Нині у Верховній Раді розглядають варіант тимчасового встановлення максимальної ставки розмитнення автівок,
які завезли в Україну з порушенням митних правил до кінця 2020 року.
Сума не має перевищувати однієї тисячі євро.
Вже є два законопроєкти зі змінами до Податкового та Митного кодексів,
і профільний комітет парламенту рекомендує ухвалити їх за основу.
Отримані кошти планують направити на вакцинацію українців та доплати медикам.
Але порозумітися так і не вдається, бо держава не хоче втрачати надходження до бюджету від акцизу,
а "євробляхери" вимагають його взагалі скасувати.
Уряд і Верховна Рада проти такого радикального кроку, адже якщо скасувати акциз,
то бюджет недоотримає мільярди гривень. Акциз на уживані автомобілі в рази більший, ніж на нові.
Це, зокрема, мало б спонукати українців пересідати на нові машини, але через економічну кризу мало хто може це собі дозволити.
За даними асоціації "Укравтопром", у жовтні, приміром, на українські номери перейшли майже 40 тисяч вживаних легковиків,
завезених з-за кордону. Це майже в півтора рази більше, ніж роком раніше.
При цьому в жовтні українці придбали лише вісім з половиною тисяч нових легкових автомобілів.
Тобто реєстрація імпортованого секонд-хенду на колесах майже вп'ятеро перевищила ринок нових авто.
Скільки точно нині в Україні автівок з іноземними номерами, достеменно невідомо.
Ще 2-3 роки тому експерти говорили про понад два мільйони нерозмитнених автомобілів.
Нині ж, за різними оцінками, близько одного мільйона.
Але придатних до розмитнення "блях" значно менше,
адже у багатьох водіїв немає всього пакету документів, необхідного для розмитнення.
Поліція довгий час не чіпала "євробляхерів", але останнім часом почала штрафувати. Зокрема, у Харкові вже виписували такі штрафи.
"Євробляхери" вважають це перевищенням повноважень і порушенням меморандуму з МВС.
Вони поскаржилися президенту й ініціювали відповідну петицію.
Зеленський, судячи з усього, не хоче налаштовувати цих водіїв проти себе
і вимагає від парламенту перегляду умов розмитнення.
Опитані DW експерти скептично оцінюють такі слабкі спроби влади і "євробляхерів" домовитися.
Мовляв, чим довше влада буде загравати з "євробляхерами",
тим нахабнішими ставатимуть їхні вимоги.
Але, за словами Сергія Фурси, нинішня влада занадто популістична,
щоб ухвалювати якесь кінцеве рішення, і достатньо якихось 10 автомобілів, які б перекрили вулицю Грушевського,
аби влада поступилася. Владі слід продемонструвати тверду позицію, переконаний експерт,
бо якщо піти на умови "євробляхерів", це вирішить одну проблему, але створить дві нові:
суттєве зменшення надходжень до бюджету і подальше забруднення повітря в українських містах , зокрема у Києві.
За словами Сергія Фурси, одна з головних причин погіршення якості повітря в столиці -
це "нашестя євроблях", викиди від яких не відповідають екологічним стандартам.